I'm with you I'm a cannabis grower
I specialized in marijuana and everything
I had to see around
from how to change a
how to use a varietal line and
7 years ago I was imprisoned for fewer plants
of which today one can have
legally in uruguay
[Music]
for growing cannabis for me consumption
personal
he considered that it was worse than a
drug dealer because I had the
knowledge and the ability to produce
a substance of very good quality I
gave two years and four months
when you enter the module and form
the cops that are going to give you your
welcome is a line of 10 policemen
on each side to his stick and a dog give you
They are many seconds that you do not forget
[Music]
several days of visit all these people are going
to visit your loved ones visit
It has two parts when the guard
call and say your visit came and then the
Upset when the visit goes away I think
that are the worst
[Music]
we were watching a movie with the
guys and they kicked the door for us
it was the violence with which he entered
It was very mobilizing and a very abrupt
but here we were, I have a picture in the
phone is still secret from juan del
2006 when he wore a beard
now it's a series of hours put in
the family the shoulder and not only looked after
the family but taking care of me
in also but one does not have its
ground wire and where to return
and his life project to follow is not
misses
the prisons are formators of
delinquents
in that period it was a study a lot
of course I had much more time was a
weirdo
my apprenticeships in prison good
they were botany the books laws because
you had to shred all that stuff
legal written in a language that is not
that is not understood to tests so
complicated for an ordinary person
I am 40 years old and about carry this and if
I would have had 20 that had happened to me
the next prisoner grower may have
those 20 years and your life will be shattered
here I think that was what I
motivated to leave jail with many
forces to fight
in Uruguay, consumption and
have a small amount but there was not
a lawful way to get that
quantity and if you buy it from a
trafficker was not punishable self-produced
had taken me there then it was
illogical because that amount of carriage
legal the law itself forced to buy it
to a trafficker then justice
he was in collusion with the
drug trafficking when we arrived at
raise that to the supreme court that
we made a march towards the supreme
cut and deliver our sailer thesis
völler the spokesman of the supreme court
raúl oxandabarat and said
the law has gaps and they started there
drop everything like dominoes the
legislators took that and they went to
talk to activists if you were going to
change the law if you were going to refute a
good article and that's where we started
29 senators
and they have done it for the affirmative and 13 and
they have done it because of the refusal
tried in general the bill the
Senate enters the discussion
[Applause]
[Music]
marijuana moves a lot of money
around 50 million dollars
a year for the world very little but
for Uruguay quite a lot if we
we took the eye drug trafficking if it were a
single company any company to which
you take 50 million dollars from
your cash flow has consequences a
optional
[Music]
the heels are thrown and this is where
we make the first selection
the psychoactive substance that we
We are looking for is located in the plant
glandular level does not run like a sap
they have a little body like a scion that
he holds a head and his head is
filled with an oil that are the
cannabinoids
when for this for this harvest the
club is 100 at least head and
Juan's responsibility with our hand
of work not only learning
[Music]
[Applause]
is going to have a cannabis expo is the
the first time that in Uruguay a
exhibition of all items of the
cannabis
that is starting to look like a
holland a barcelona
how many times of laughter
grand bourg
[Music]
the only way there is regulation and
this has no turning back the world
goes to that road I alone in Uruguay
when we visualize this and we
we put to work in the realization was
a mountain that we had to climb
when we reached the top we were going to
hug we were going to plant the flag
We were going to put on some concerts
happy because marijuana was going to be
legalized we reached the summit of the
mountain with the average flag reality and
when we looked there was a valley another
Montana
we have to keep going
[Music]
and
but